you're saying you're a dog from the
future
made a big mistake we're supposed to
stay at 8/7 central w hey everybody its
charlie we got new flash footage to
break down of the villain and more
details about the hundredth episode New
York Comic Con is also this week so
there's a whole bunch of footage coming
that I'll talk about at the end of the
video there'll be a bunch of trailers
coming in the next couple of days I'm
still doing the giveaway for that DC
streaming service all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video we finally got our
first look as Chris Klein as cicada
we've seen his eyebrows but most of the
time you've seen him in the trailers
with the mask on but you know what Chris
Klein looks like so there's no big
surprises here he's not gonna be wearing
any giant prosthetics or anything like
that
obviously he looks very different from
the old version of cicada from the
comics so there are some Easter eggs for
that original version of the character
like there's some one that he lost that
he's trying to get back and that's kind
of what comic book cicada was trying to
do but then went totally off the rails
and the person that he loved who did
eventually come back from the dead his
wife in that case turned against him so
the whole thing with cicada during
season 5 is that Barry just got his
daughter like he learned that she exists
this is such an awesome thing so he
gained a daughter but cicada lost his
because of things that metahumans were
doing we finally got a description for
episode 2 it's called blocked and it
actually introduces his character in a
really big way
so we'll just read the description here
it says as Barry helps his daughter Nora
become a better speedster he and team
flash also tracked down a meta stealing
high-tech weapons only to cross paths
with a new foe named cicada who is
hunting the very same meta with
nefarious intent so the whole metaphor
behind the title blocked is all about
how cicadas powers work he can use that
Speed Force dagger to take people's
powers away it's much easier to kill
someone when you take their powers away
he mostly just wants to get rid of all
metahumans the good ones and the bad
ones
so week to week team flash is obviously
trying to get rid of the bad metahumans
that are doing evil things in the city
but cicada is also on this righteous
quest to get rid of them too so they run
into each other in episode 2 both
tracking down the same meta so early
prediction he kills that meta at the end
of episode 2 and it serves as
foreshadowing for what he's going to try
and do to people on team flash like the
death of vibe was this article that
showed up in the background of some
teasers that we got from a future
episode it's probably him taking away
Cisco's powers so they're using episode
two to sort of foreshadow how he does
that so it's the same kind of thing that
they do every season like they give you
a tutorial in the mechanics of how the
villains powers work in the first couple
of episodes so that when he does
something really crazy to team flash
later on it makes sense Jessica Parker
Kennedy who plays Nora was talking more
about her character she says she wants
to make her dad really happy she's just
there to impress him meet him get to
know him better but obviously on route 2
that she created a big mistake by
altering the timeline yes she does
actually have those Speed Force symbols
on her costume the ones that she was
writing down during season four so the
mystery of what those symbols are
exactly we kind of have an idea because
Barry was writing them down spouting out
language from the future so it's sort of
this grand cosmic key that's going to
help them unlock and solve all the
problems this season but it's kind of
like a MacGuffin this point like
something that's not super important but
they use it to drive the plot forward
then the real payoff will be them fixing
the future without completely destroying
secada but the whole idea is is that
Barry defeats the villain but I think
they try to find a better solution than
just like stabbing them in the face like
Oliver would try to do so the first
couple of episodes are all about setting
up the JJ Abrams mystery boxes of the
season like these are the big questions
that we're going to answer then slowly
answering most of those by the
mid-season finale and teeing up a whole
bunch of new ones for the back half
right now they're still filming that
hundredth episode anniversary we found
out that they're actually filming at
Barry Allen's childhood home so they're
probably going to be going back to the
night that his mother was murdered in
referencing that usually hundreds
episodes like the arrow hundredth
episode are all about fanservice
giving you the fan favorites bringing
back the most important characters and
showing you the past present and future
of the character like Barry Allen this
is your life your daughter from the
future your past with the reverse-flash
the night your mother was murdered
the producers already teased that they
would be bringing back a lot of fan
favorite characters I think that they're
implying that they're gonna bring back
reverse-flash no it could be original
reverse-flash from the pilot or it could
be the new version of reverse fly
or we could get a version of both
because usually when you go back to the
night Barry's mother was murdered
they just replay footage from the pilot
so if they show that footage again it's
not like they're gonna edit in a brand
new reverse flash they're just gonna
copy paste that clip into whatever it is
is happening during the episode and if
we get to meet the new reverse flash
because they did tease you no one wonder
what face I'll be wearing next when I
meet it'll be some completely separate
scene but I know you had all kinds of
questions about which other characters
are gonna show up we haven't had too
many teasers about that I think that's
just because they're filming most of
those scenes indoors so it's not like
you're gonna get big paparazzi shots of
them walking around on the street
together so knowing what they did for
arrows hundredth episode what do you
want them to do for the Flash's
hundredth episode because remember like
not everybody made it back for that
episode they did Deathstroke but Manu
Bennett wasn't around they talked about
Tommy but Tommy wasn't actually in the
episode Stephen Amell was also posting
again recently about the crossover
episode because that's episode 9 so some
people have started to film for that he
did tease that he gets a new outfit but
he actually came on my tweet when I was
like oh yay that means you know new
costume he's actually pretty funny when
he jumps onto people's tweets because he
just said no meaning that he's not
wearing a new green arrow costume or
like a new superhero costume so of
course people are going crazy with
theories because new outfit could just
mean new clothes that he's wearing he
could just be having fun with people
because there's a version of Oliver
Queen that's in prison right now
obviously he'll probably get out during
the arrow midseason finales so that the
back half of the season they can do
Oliver out of prison trying to take down
two longbow hunters but I've seen a
whole bunch of crazy theories about him
playing the Batman of the other earth
that they go to where bat woman is from
I don't think it's gonna be anything
like that I think it's totally possible
he could be playing an alternate version
of Oliver Queen but just remember that
he got a new mould of himself made and
he still fits in to his old Green Arrow
costume so they're not making a new
Green Arrow costume so why would they
need to take a mold of him to make a
costume when you don't really do that
for regular clothes so it just implies
that there's gonna be something funny
that they're gonna build that looks like
Oliver Queen or that he'll be wearing
during the crossover I don't think we're
gonna see footage for that till at least
late October early November the
crossover is happening later
in december than it normally would so
it's still gonna be a ways off this week
is New York comic-con I don't know if
they're gonna drop any new footage for
the shows because they're promoting a
bunch of other stuff like Titans is
doing its big worldwide premiere I
actually had to double-check the embargo
on that I can't post my review till
tomorrow morning so Thursday morning is
when I'll post that there was a new
spider-man far from home video that just
drops I'll do new video for that a lot
of spider-man stuff happening right now
if you haven't seen it yet click here
for my non-spoilery venom review and
click here to learn all about the flash
arrow 3-way crossover this year thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome see you guys tonight
[Music]